why you should learn how to deploy to
Cloud run using Cloud deploy my first
experience with Cloud run was refreshing
I had a python app that I could directly
deploy from source code with a single
gcloud command didn't have to figure out
how to write a Docker file didn't have
to write a any complex deploy config
but I also understand that as an org
adopts serverless rigor between
separating pre-prod and prod
environments and actually having a
proper deployment mechanism that isn't
your laptop is important that's why we
have a tutorial that walks through
exactly how you can use cloud deploy as
that mechanism to promote an app through
different Cloud run environments so if
you want to build pipelines to deploy to
pre-prod and prod environments in Cloud
run check out the tutorial Linked In the
pinned comment where you'll see for
yourself